liebe sportfreunde es ist der wahnsinn
wie die zeit vergeht ist ein
mittlerweile in der sechsten
trainingswoche heute am montag wir
starten mit einer intensiven workout mit
euch wir machen militärisch fitness
haider mal ein bisserl anders das heißt
eine 20 10 die belastung zu anderen
sechs übungen eine durchgehende
belastung mit serien pause so dass es
für jedermann schaffbar ist der gerry
ist der herbert ist altbekannt ist peter
binder und wir werden euch gemeinsam
durch die nächste halbe stunde führen
und gewisse neuere neue dinge zeigen und
gewisse dinge die ihr leben am besten
gallows lockeres aufwärmen und das ist
das was man heute gern mal etwas anders
gestaltet werden das heißt einerseits
kann ich aufwärmen in dem ich
schattenboxen
andererseits kann immer an denis boizow
hernehmen und den am boden brillen mich
dazu bewegen schritte links rechts
oberkörper bewegen eine minute gehts los
und wenn ihr da schaut der handwechsel
die bewegung ich habe den ellbogen in
bewegung das handgelenk arbeitet das
kniegelenk das sprunggelenk die hüfte
ich bin aber überall in einer bewegung
drinnen so dass sie da einen gewissen
effekt des mobilisieren drinnen habe
ohne dass eine entsprechende extrem hohe
belastung bereits zu haben
und auch beim schattenboxen sowieso aber
bereits fix mit dabei habe handy mit
dabei habe eine rotation aus dem
oberkörper drinnen ist in dem er
vielleicht einmal auf einen geschlagenen
haken heraus rolle
diese varianten sind im schattenboxen
alle mit drin
das heißt super variante um mich auch
entsprechend aufzuwärmen
das ganze heute ohne energie das heißt
ohne wirklichen punch aber schön locker
in die luft geschlagen dann ist es ein
gute variante ok eine minute haben wir
bereits das heißt kurz damit durch
schlafen weil wie gesagt anstrengend ist
wenn man nur in die luft hat oder mit
einem tennisball sie entsprechend bewegt
dann macht man mal ganz kurz eine
rotationsbewegung für die wirbelsäule wo
man so relativ schwierig reinkommen das
oberkörper in der vorbeuge leichter
gerät stand und arme links und rechts
bewegen
das ist natürlich mit schattenboxen
schwer kombinierbar
deswegen war mir dass das extra übung
noch dazu mit ein gott wieder aufrichten
durch bewegen durchschütteln zweite
runde schattenboxen zweite runde
tennisbällen geht schon los wir machen
gleich wieder eine minute bewegen herz
kreislauf system kommt gut in schwung
und der körper wird auf die nachfolgende
belastung entsprechend vorbereitet und
dort die militärische fitness military
fitness wort ist jetzt immer eine der
anstrengendsten einheiten die wir
gemacht haben
und so ist es auch jetzt das heißt wir
müssen den körper wirklich wirklich
darauf vorbereiten was am belastung
jetzt dann folgt und da muss ich ja
schon beim aufwärmen entsprechend dann
gefördert werden
gefordert seien zehn sekunden kurz
ausschied und kurz aus lockern wir
beginnen die erste runde muskuläres
vorbereiten das heißt wir machen jetzt
nicht sieben wiederholungen sondern beim
ersten durchgang nur 34 mal 3 das heißt
drei liegestütz 33 sieht ab dreimal
rücken aufrichten geht's los
[Applaus]
gerner guter wechsel kniebeuge dann
gleitet sit ups traf zwei und drei
wechsel in die bauchlage und wenn durch
aufstehen und wir gehen in die dritte
boxende wir wissen das amateurboxen hat
wir machen jetzt alle dritte
schattenboxen beziehungsweise aufwärmen
mit dem tennisball und geht's los
[Applaus]
militärisches boxen haben wir zusätzlich
dabei den kniestoß und einen
entsprechenden stopp tritt das kann man
mit einbauen dann haben wir die hüfte
mit drinnen mobilisiert und aufgewärmt
geht mit vorderen und mit dem hinteren
beim körper weise und auch hier mit dem
tennisball habe einerseits die
körperliche komponente und andererseits
die koordination mit dabei das heißt sie
mussten in den s-bahnen mich jedes mal
wieder treffen und weiter brennen auch
da unterschiedliche varianten möglich
20 sekunden lang
[Applaus]
10 und ausschlafen durchschlafen kurz
regenerieren kurz rausnehmen
jetzt haben wir das herz kreislaufsystem
glaube ich ganz gut in schwung brachte
herbert wie schatz petit aus der herz
kreislauf system ist normal da genau
jetzt schauen wir uns eine übung an die
kennt sie zu hause machen wasserflasche
leichtes zusatzgewicht oder auch einmal
zum probieren ganz ohne der turkish geld
ab eine übung aus dem catwalk training
eine stabilisationsübungen und das
schauen wir uns jetzt der die ersten
teilschritte davon an der gehry zeigt
euch das einmal vor eine super spannungs
übung und aufgebaut
ihr legt sich an meinem rücken hin
winkels einmal das rechte bein ab und
streckt die rechte hand nach oben
ob das jetzt gleich mit zusatzgewicht
ist oder ohne das lassen wir mal dass
man mehr aus das heißt erst die bewegung
ihr geht es einmal nach oben das heißt
ihr stützt sich am ellbogen ab zweiter
bewegung ihr streckte ellbogen dritte
bewegung ihr drückt das becken durch und
das ist es mit dem wir dann heute schon
aufhören da geht sagte einmal die
bewegung fertig das haus durch steigen
und dann aufrichten und aufstehen genau
und das ganze geht natürlich bergab auch
wieder schritt zurück runter greifen
durch jetzt wieder aufs gesäß auf den
ellbogen und ablegen
okay das ist die gesamte bewegung wir
machen die ersten drei teilschritten
jeweils fünf wiederholungen ihr fang
zumal zu hause an ohne gewicht im ersten
durchgang und dann seht ihr wie das gut
funktionieren kann
ok also in die rückenlage rechtes bein
anwinkeln rechte hand nach oben strecken
schritt eins nur auf den eltern gehen
genau spannen und wieder runter fünf
wiederholungen 123
und eine noch eine fünfte runde gehen
und jetzt nimmt die atmung ag mit dazu
vielleicht haben sie schon gehört wenn
ihr hoch geht's ab märz aus los die luft
raus und dann runter gehen einatmen
das heißt schritt nummer 1 und 2
kombiniert auf den ellbogen und auf die
hand genau und wieder runter einmal und
zwei mal gerne wichtig ist darum fest
gespannt der brauch ist gespannt
ja und ich habe ein gutes gefühl für
ihren körper machen wir noch eine
wiederholung gemeinsam ellbogen hand und
wieder runter und im dritten schritt ist
einmal kurz auslagern
kurz die spannung heraus im dritten
schritt ellbogen hand und das becken
hochdrücken ja schatz noch mit so einer
ellbogen hand und becken sterner und
wieder runter becken absetzen album
absetzen und wir darunter gerne und das
machen wir jetzt noch viermal erste
durchgang geht schon los
ellbogen hand becken hoch hintern
anspannen und wieder runter 123 nächste
wiederholung ellbogen hand becken hoch
und wieder runter und eine wiederholung
auch ellbogen hand deckenhoch sehr gut
kurz aus locker kurz durchschnaufen wir
machen gleich die zweite seite dazu
damit man es nicht einseitig noch an
beide seiten werden trainiert kurz mal
durchschnaufen linkes knie anwinkeln
linke hand nach oben strecken alles
unter spannung alles ist vorbereitet
ellbogen hand becken das ist die
bewegung die man machen
ok wieder runter
und jetzt teilweise wieder auf nur den
ellbogen 5 mal 1 2 und 3 4 und einmal
noch von fünf kurz aus lockern kurz die
spannung raus vorbereiten im kopf
ellbogen und hand geht los 1234
und ein letztes mal noch einen fünften
noch 95 kurz aus laupheim kurz
ausschütteln die gesamte bewegung jetzt
der in drei teilschritten album hand
becken vier wiederholungen volle
körperspannung als vorbereitung für das
was dann kommt für das workout auf die
idee die sechs übungen oder fünf übungen
die man danach machen werden eine gute
vorbereitung
los gehts ellbogen hand becken erster
durchgang zwei
304 aus lockern abspannen hochkommen
durchschnaufen gehts los
karim 805 habe da sehr brav jetzt die
spannung raus aufstehen auslagern
das weist die muskuläre vorbereitung für
den rumpf für die spannung schulter
heraus rumpfmuskulatur und jetzt glaube
ich haben wir ganz gut ready for action
das heißt für das training bereit wir
gehen uns noch mal gemeinsam die übungen
durch damit ihr dann wisst beim wechsel
war es ja machen muss wie das ganze
ausschaut das heißt die erste übung
macht man wieder in zwei varianten
elevator liegestütz erste variante wäre
bitter beine nach oben irgendwo erhöht
knie sind gestreckt bobo ist gespannt
und nach oben und nach unten gehen erste
übung danke jamie du nimmst ein
zusatzgewicht ob das jetzt eine kette
bell ist ob das arosa ist ein gefühlter
des kennzeichens frei wählen wir machen
jetzt einmal keine liegestütz sondern
wie das bankdrücken das gewicht nach
oben stemmen das gewicht nehmen und geht
schon los
nach oben stemmen und wieder nach unten
stimmen genau
okay das ist die erste übung die zweite
übung gary das raster ja sagen wir vor
[Applaus]
also kniebeuge mit gewicht und nach oben
stemmen wenn ihr kein zusatzgewicht habt
ist das problem ja dann macht sie eine
saubere tiefe kniebeuge und stets nach
oben das ist gut
ich habe deine variante quasi die
rucksack variante kniebeuge gewicht nach
oben stemmen sehr gut übungen nummer
drei candlestick mit zusatzgewicht die
übung kendzia schon die haben wir schon
mal gemacht
passt aber in dieses workout sehr gut
hinein
gewicht vor der brust nach hinten
vorkommen ausgleichen zurück hoch in die
kerze vorkommen ausgleichen gerner
dritte übung stadt hama zweite variante
des gens über machen im freien auf der
parkbank wenn er laufen geht es
entsprechend irgendwo eine bank dass die
ruder bewegung auf der bank das us team
setzen beine strecken und wieder
zurückziehen ähnlich wie man es macht
dann fit am arbeitsplatz kann man das
natürlich als bad bank challenge als
parkbank workout sehen und nahm seinen
lauf bewegungen oder spazierte
bewegungen natürlich auch die
bauchmuskulatur entsprechend aktivieren
okay es sind bekannt welche variante
bremer fans ab hände weg und wieder hoch
red du machst dir mal vor
[Applaus]
okay das heißt runtergehen in den
liegestuhl und knie zum 11 seitlich vor
bewegen super komplexe übung super
schwierig ja das ist die nächste
variante und letzte übung tipps so
machst engeli gestützt und du machst auf
erhöhung genau das heißt hände ganz
knapp zueinander körperspannung aufbauen
tief runter und wieder hofft ganz enge
liegestütze und herbert der eine option
ist gibt es auch auf der parkbank
machbar überhaupt kein problem
das heißt runtergehen und wieder
hochgehen werde schwierig an die streckt
die beine
wer es ein bisschen einfacher möchte
wirklich die beine ab dann ist das wie
sie weniger zukauf der muskulatur aber
genauso anstrengend deshalb die übungen
die man machen und vom zeitlichen anhalt
her ist das jetzt so wir machen von
jeder übung zehn wiederholungen
das heißt das gesamte wird dauernd 23
minuten dann haben wir eine runde dann
machen wir kurze pause und dann wieder
holen wir das ganz so scharf wie oft sie
das ganze ausgeht das ist das workout
auf die idee das heißt übungen
durchgehend ohne pause ich sage immer
wieder dazu so dass wir gut mitmachen
könnt vorbereiten anstalt trinken
errichten was ihr braucht
der etwas gab's
wie schnell sammer bei den fünf übungen
[Applaus]
genau wir schauen dass man ordentliche
ausführung haben dass man technisch das
perfekt und richtig machen und weniger
auf die zeit sondern wir schauen
wirklich auf eine technisch exakte
ausführung habe dies bereits
die agentur ist bereits jetzt zu hause
bereit wir legen los erste übung
elevator liegestütz beziehungsweise das
bankdrücken mit einem zusatzgewicht bei
einer abhängigen beine ausstrecken so
lange die wirbelsäule die
lendenwirbelsäule fixiert am boden habt
beide varianten gut
ok dann würde ich weiß lang und ihr
zuhause genauso ja zehn wiederholungen
liegestütz in der überhöhten variante
oder auch ein gewicht nach oben stemmen
mit voller körperspannung das beginnt
beim kniegelenk was durchgestreckt ist
die regelung durchstrecken ja nächsten
durchgang entsprechend und hört dann auf
herum geschäftsleitung der trust die
nicht nehmen kniebeuge vorbereiten und
nach oben stoßen
damit seien zwischendrin das drk
wiederholung fehlt zehn mal gesagt
manchmal das ganze
gewichts sauber kontrolliert absetzen
candlesticks nächste variante bzw
für dich bad bank sieht ups bereits los
geht's zehn wiederholungen saubere
technische ausführung spannen
rumpfmuskulatur ist in action zwei
übungen bleiben die bdp ist und die
tipps aber das wird kommen das
wiederholen hast du ja bitte sag ja
durch neun von zehn gewicht aber
kontrolliert ablegen bereitmachen
aufstehen büskens ab salamander geht's
los 10 auch bei den sprüngen
da ist natürlich ganz klar da kommt das
herz kreislauf system wieder voll auf
touren haben wir beim aufwärmen der
asche mit dabei gehabt auch hier achtet
auf eure beinachse auf eure klapper
stabilität deshalb die dinge die immer
wichtig sein und gerade bei so
dynamischen übungen absolut im
vordergrund stehen durch letzte übung
tipps bereit machen
doch man kann eigentlich gestützt und
tipps auf der parkbank geht's los zehn
wiederholungen
[Applaus]
und wie gesagt nehmt euch die übungen
her love 200 meter macht den durchgang
läuft wieder bei 100 meter laufs bewegt
sich und macht perfekt auch als autor
burkhard möglich okay wir haben genau
drei minuten takt für diesen einen
durchgang jetzt einmal durchschnaufen
herausnehmen am stand bewegen ausgehen
und das ganze wärme wiederholen ja weil
glaubt mit arme haben wir noch nicht den
reiz thema brauchen als zweites
vielleicht sogar drittes oder viertes
mal geht sie da sicherlich aus und je
besser durch das passt gut
wie lange schaut mal pause machen gerne
was sagst du zwei minuten ungefähr genau
das ist ja mal nicht schlecht ja das
heißt man das werden wir uns auch halten
dass du in die pause zu lang erscheint
der kann natürlich schon mit übungen im
vorfeld staaten wenn sie so zu kurz
erscheint da kann natürlich nur
vielleicht 20 sekunden zeit hat zu
werden auch mit durchschnaufen und ein
schluck trinken und dann loslegen aber
summa summarum zu schaffen dass man
diese drei minuten belastung öfters
hintereinander machen kann und wie
gesagt das werk hat im vordergrund steht
und nicht die pause die minuten waren
vorbei ich glaube meine heute und dann
legen wir wieder los mit der ersten
übung elevator liegestütz
beziehungsweise deine variante
bankdrücken ausgangspositionen einnehmen
in 15 sekunden geht's los sagt norma der
männer volle körperspannung beginnend
ganz beim bei der zehenspitze an enden
bei der letzten beim letzten worte
vorgesagt in dem fall
bei der letzten fingerspitze devils
arbeitszeit ist wieder voll mit dabei
das geht relativ rasch zu machen zehn
wiederholungen sagen gleich durch
station wechseln gewicht polen
vorbereiten für die frosta kniebeuge mit
anstoßen nach oben und schloss
halbzeitshow fünf wiederholungen seiner
statur sehr gut zwei dicke des steaks
die braucht übung bad bank oder auf der
matte vorbereiten und geht's los und
immer wieder ausgleichen versuchen nicht
die fersen abzusetzen bei den
candlesticks sondern immer wieder aus
dem gleichgewicht heraus zurückgestoßen
die beine geht und wieder vorkommen auch
auf der parkbank ausgleichen beine
rasieren geistert die zehn
wiederholungen durch abstehen
die ansprechendste übung für das herz
kreislauf system bleibt bis zehn
wiederholungen wie gesagt ohne pause
gleich wieder los 8 auf die beinachse
achten auf die körperspannung dynamisch
hoch springen kontrolliert landen auf
dessen es immer wieder achten immer
wieder kontrollieren und immer wieder
drauf schauen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und natürlich dieses workout kennt mit
15 g 20 wiederholungen machen ja oder 15
überhaupt kein thema abwechselnde
übungen oberen extremität unteren
extremität bauchmuskulatur und in diesem
wechsel premier mahnte nächste übung
letzte übung gips beziehungsweise in
enge liegestütz aber durch schlafen
arbeiten geht los und jetzt jetzt des
anstrengen da geht es richtig zur sache
nicht nur bei uns so also bei uns hier
sondern auch bei euch zu hause das darf
so sein dass sollte sein
das ist ein workout und das darf auch
anstrengend sein
kurz durchschnaufen runde gehen kann und
ich bin sicher ihr zuhause satz bereit
für ihren dritten durchgang und den
wärmer am morgen gerne da wird ja noch
mal gute minuten baute und dann braucht
man an dritten durchgang weil man schon
gesagt haben auf wir haben mit
schattenboxen drei runden hauptteil mit
militärischen es drei runden muss ein
bisschen druck lastet aber das scherzo
das pastor gefüttert
[Applaus]
das ist die einzig vor immerhin es soll
körperlich belastend sein
es eröffnet überfordern aber nicht
unterfordern damit man entsprechend
entscheiden trainings wirksamen reiz da
auf die auf die matte oder entsprechend
auf trainingsgeräten bringen dass wir
uns entwickeln können
sollte der zu diesem werk fragen haben
beziehungsweise generell sportliche
fragen haben ddr aus sie zu hause am pc
beantwortet ich gerne jede frage also
zeichnet postet kommentiert und teils
den beitrag dann kann man viele mit
trainieren und ja nicht nur wir drei
sondern auch hier zu hause macht sich
bereit
wir starten los mit dem dritten
durchgang wenn ihr bereit seid übrigens
immer danke groß elevator liegestütz
komplexe übung oberen extremitäten
strecker shooter natürlich mit dabei
körperspannung sowieso und bis
bankdrücken sommer ein post muss
gestärkt mit drinnen aber volle
körperliche belastung zweite übung
frosta gewicht zur hand zehn
wiederholungen einmal position
vorbereiten und los geht's das amt
annehmen den beinen natürlich ganz stark
hinter shooter mit drinnen weil das
gewicht nach oben sternen stemmen
erfordert natürlich explosive
entwicklung der kraft aus dem shooter
muskel
von zehn wiederholungen hammer dritte
übung übung candlesticks oder auf
unserer simulierten parkbank beine
strecken ausgleichen gleichgewicht
halten beim hochkommen versuchen so gut
es geht nicht am boden anzukommen
das ist wichtig körperspannung halten
atmen dazu sauerstoff in die muskulatur
eine lassen sehen wiederholungen gleich
armatur jawohl super aufstehen
durchschlafen aktiv und dann geht es
weiter bis zehn wiederholungen hands up
salamander geht los fürs herz kreislauf
system richtig richtig voran das heißt
wenn jetzt der die daten die
datengeschwindigkeit steigt das ist in
ordnung ja keine sorge reguliert sie
dann eben anstrengend soll es sein
anstrengend ist es auch
[Applaus]
aber gott sei dank zehn wiederholungen
seiner greifer bei letzte tipps bzw
schmale liegestütz fünfte über dritter
durchgang letzte übung zeit läuft zehn
wiederholungen tempo abarbeiten
[Applaus]
die pflegestufe tipps genau
körperspannung richtig beißen richtig
beißen durch sommer gott gemacht tolles
werk komponiert der nato nach einer
harten körperlichen belastung ihr wisst
es mittlerweile schon muss man natürlich
hat das system hat immer runter fahren
ja und da immer vorn im regulieren ihm
runter kommen ist es wichtig zu bewegen
durchzuschlafen und alt-ob bietet sie
glaube das schattenboxen zum
regenerieren gar nicht so schlecht an
das heißt wir machen alle lockere minute
schattenboxen ja und damit können wir
das herz kreislauf system aber wieder
regulieren aber zuerst einmal 34 arten
zu tief luft holen
zur luft kommen und dann nochmal minute
gemeinsame schattenboxen schaut gut aus
einer minute bitter lockere
schattenboxen ganz locker zum entspannen
da ist nichts mehr nichts mehr aggressiv
ist dabei von der bewegung von der
dynamik her sondern da geht es ganz
locker dass dieser spielerisches bewegen
mit auslaufenden händen und beinen mit
dabei
[Applaus]
genau ganz locker runter fahren das
system den körper langsam zeit sich von
der belastung auch wieder zu erholen
[Applaus]
20 sekunden noch zähne schöne position
genau 32 11 wieder durchschnaufen
auslagern ausschütten
ich würde vorschlagen nachdem die
rückenmuskulatur die wirbelsäule da
immer unter spannung hatten bei diversen
übungen nehmen die mobilisation der
lendenwirbelsäule noch dazu ist setzt
sich am nieder beine anwinkeln und lasse
mir die knie links und rechts zum boden
herunter einfach versuchen da bislang
dynamiker reinzubringen aufrecht oder
ihr kennt sicher dabei mehr hinlegen da
kommen ja noch in den bereich der
brustwirbelsäule hinein weil man durch
mehr bewegung noch drinnen haben
wichtig ist dass es jetzt ruhig und
entspannt ist hat nimmt er meint kräh
schied ja und lasse mir die zehn innen
und nach außen fallen nach innen
rotieren nach außen rotieren
es ist hörbar es ist spürbar der druck
kommt heraus die regeneration selbst
bereits sein okay stehen wir noch mal
auf was ist dein lieblings übung im
regenerieren im cool down prozess
schwung nach oben schwingen wie kennst
das entweder in der aufrechten position
oder einer vorfeier locker vor zurück
schwingen da kriegt sie einfach eine
schöne dynamik hinein
die gute regeneration ist nur mit dem
oberkörper verdrehen oberkörper kreisen
ist der nasa möglichkeiten in diesem
schwung zu regenerieren etwas belastung
heraus zu nehmen wenn er sagt danke für
das intensive tolle workout für euch zu
hause
wir haben jetzt drei hunden macht
spricht gar nichts dagegen vierte oder
fünfte runde er zu machen
es war total cool mit heute wieder zu
trainieren wir sehen uns morgen zur
nächsten einheit wir sind da und wir
halten